Urban dictionary defines a jump scare as
a technique used by unimaginative
filmmakers as a cheap method of
frightening the audience.
And judging by a lot of comments on my
last video,
people tend to agree with this
definition.
I agreed that the jump scare has lost
its former glory,
not only our movie saturated with them.
I think many filmmakers are using them
completely wrong.
But where I disagree with a lot of
people is that I think there's still
hope for the jump scare and people don't
give them nearly enough credit for how
amazing they can beat.
So let's see what they can do.
And if you can't handle all the jump
scares why you are nothing but a great
big coward,
you Roy
and its simplest form,
a jump scare is a jarring cut,
usually accompanied by a frightening
sound.
To illustrate this technique,
let's look at an example that's not from
a horror movie
shoots
ticket one time.
Okay?
Now what makes this more than a cheap
jump scare?
What's important is that it not only
scares,
but it outlines a major plot point that
resonates throughout the Lord of the
rings trilogy.
With a jump scare.
We see how the ring can turn the kind
bilbo into an evil and terrifying
creature.
A jump scare was without a doubt the
best way to show the terrors of the ring
firsthand.
So now for the rest of their adventure
that jumps gear sticks with us and
reminds us how high the stakes are and
how powerful the ring is.
Great.
Think jumps gears are misunderstood,
is that they're supposed to do much more
than just give us a simple startle.
A jump scare should add tension to the
rest of the movie by making us distrust
any moment where we feel safe after
being startled,
once were put on high alert and with
every long pause or dark shadow we
experience afterwards,
there's a heightened suspense and
alertness because now we question
everything we see.
This is where many filmmakers use the
jump scare rung when used correctly.
The technique makes the call moments of
the movie scary too.
Places down it can wander in and out of
any panic night
scare should function like real life.
Once he gets scared.
Once you're scared for the rest of the
night,
they're great movies like the witch that
use very subtle and infrequent jump
scares.
They aren't scary themselves,
but the quick cuts in change in sound
still add to the overall suspense of the
movie.
The technique is done wrong when it's
used too often and isn't punctuated with
suspiciously calm and suspenseful scenes
like when silent hill revelation makes a
jump scare out of literally everything
including a pop tart.
Actually,
I take it back.
You can use a toaster for an effective
job,
but it's the great buildup that does it
trick.
Another misunderstanding is that people
don't know what makes a jump scare good.
Take this of the technique from watch
Mojo's video on the top 10 jump scares
of all time.
It's a one two punch of a scary face and
a loud noise and that's exactly what
makes it jump scare.
So effective.
This is a completely wrong way to
analyze jump scares.
The most important part is not the scare
itself.
It's the 30 seconds of buildup before
the scare buildup is what separates the
good jump scare from the cheap one.
Here's a simple example from the sixth
sense,
the 10 opens at the top left of the
frame and moves to the bottom right
along with the camera.
This framing guides our eyes towards the
bottom right where a jump scare.
Oh wait,
sorry.
Yes.
This is a jump scare that doesn't
require a fast cut or even any jarring
movement to be scary.
It was the buildup from the slow camera
movement that did the trick.
Compare that to the laziest jump scare
of all time,
the bad guys showing up through the
bathroom mirror.
Okay.
There's no time for the buildup and it's
a huge cliche.
The predictable jump scare scenarios are
giving the whole technique of bad
reputation.
The best ones should go against our
expectations,
not appeal to them.
This jump scare and insidious feels so
fresh because we unconsciously expected
the scared to come from the flashback,
not from where she's telling the story.
Similarly,
with this scene in jaws,
we expected the scariest part to be when
he found the tooth,
but there's actually something much
worse waiting.
Okay,
good jump scare.
It's a lot like a magic trick.
It's all about the showmanship.
Let's use the prestige and a jump scare
from the original poltergeist to outline
this idea
if magic trick consists of three parts.
First part is called the pledge
competition shows you some old Larry
Bird or Ma Pepsi all shipped to Japan.
Did you say you usually date real?
Yeah.
Nope.
Coach probably isn't too.
The second age is called the term
magician takes the old shopping.
I might just do salad.
You're looking for the secret,
but you weren't falling because she
cooks.
No.
Want to know.
Look to be full.
Yeah,
but you wouldn't clap yet because making
something disappear isn't enough.
You have to bring it back.
That's why
every magic trick I said Third Act.
Oh,
this part,
the part we call press.
Sure.
Let's face it.
Jump scares usually suck,
but don't write them off just yet
because when used,
right,
they're pretty great and don't worry,
I won't end this video with a jump scare
or will I?
Thanks for watching.